welcome to this video playing to move to
move plenum 33 times before okay don't
really remember any of that but okay one
win two losses yeah something else maybe
let's let's do the brayer I don't know
it that well but oh that's a rare move
early a form okay okay here's some
content with d3 which is not bad of
course what can always play this some
slow kind of set up against them against
this opening oh okay let's do them
regrouping here with rook e8 Bishop f8
and get some pressure on the center so
that d 4 is not so easily played
okay so what am I going to do here c5
yeah probably yeah the question is if
you want to go see five or maybe even d5
let's see five looks very natural here
grabbing some space on the queenside
yeah okay this is a only drawback here
at this hangs huh but what if i go d5
here why not actually come let's push
this I have some good central control so
II takes and I takes will win his bishop
or we'll catch this bishop okay Queen c7
maybe just okay have 700 if I it was a
bit risky this move my coordination is
not brilliant and it like one or two
moves to and how many nice my position
okay
hmm but if I just get this sum will just
get the bishop without getting punished
for that I will be in very nice shape
here with the bishop and the space just
one day if there's some kind of
aggressive option for white don't see
anything like unites five or whatever
something yeah this is me I thought
about that but I think I can really just
take it all wait wait wait wait nah come
on let's take it interest very
interesting position now sure just play
before and kill this bishop I think I
should kill this Bishop always sounds
like something something wrong going on
okay f5 or is this too aggressive right
looks right why not grab the space h4 h5
a play gt5
yeah he wants to activate him this is
bishop I understand hmm anyway a groupie
aid what about rook a to actually can I
just attack here yea maybe then be three
didn't be 3r ooh k 1 I also like to
prevent or make sure that night b3 is
not even possible attacking my pawn on
c5 yeah no root k 1 be ready for the
rook trade what I would love to have
here's just a minor peas endgame this
would be great check can a queen 85 was
also very much coming into consideration
okay it's not a bad situation here
though I'm pretty safe here maybe Queen
a 5 a-1 trying to make use of his
somewhat awkward pieces Bishop 1 C 2
that was the reason why I wanted to
provoke be 3a make sure that night b3 is
not happening or Bishop a for those kind
of things
is there a way to activate the night
here night to h5 or 2d 424 would we
would be really great maybe I go here so
Knight f3 I can actually take difficult
for him to move now ok I just do this
end game this is a very safe way to play
this with the two bishops here want a
knight on d4 and March everything
forward him ok wants to play Bishop f3
but I would have before definitely play
before them
such hard for him to to move his pieces
94 should be should be a good way to go
here if I go back yeah I will not see
too was this some somehow yes to play 92
and now mm-hmm maybe just first the King
up and then 94 check
Jack and I doesn't have many many moves
95 maybe let's improve this Bishop first
time morning and put it here you see
somehow holding this maybe I probably
have to angle for King before him hmm
threatening just to take their now on g2
I wanted to go King c3 and i'm not sure
if it wins he has 92 one that i can take
though i only have 30 seconds damn
check the jackal is not running to and
some weird checkmate you might be three
check Jack I no no no no I can still
chat me that stupid and played this in a
very stupid way him yeah the chocolate
after this game which was very one-sided
check check like what spying or
something it's probably draw right yeah
it's it's a draw oh wow now I completely
blundered in this end game up to here
i'm sure i'm very satisfied but those
giants irritated me quite a bit yeah and
he i just did i do him I run into night
be three check which was very stupid I
was only thinking okay he takes and and
this is all good yeah no now a check can
be answered by the capture okay maybe
he'll care 20 seconds I know I can just
take him and that's that's the logical
way to to finish the game yeah he never
really did much here after this here I
don't know if this is a good good good
reaction it seems that I get get the
bishop am and I mean in good shape IAM a
computer place this more dynamically
which I missed ready yeah this is what
the engine is doing that's very
interesting
this sorry the bishop only three doesn't
have many many squares to go here and
then this which is really nice for for
black you know ok I played in a more
aesthetic way but it it it gives a great
position I mean to bishops center what
more do you want this was nice but ok I
could have played better f4 is the
computer is so brutal and wide resins
due to bishops III wow what a killer
what a killer move yeah this is really
something that happens so often in chest
when there's a particular square on the
board which is the kind of the big
blockading square here if all that
limits the pieces whenever the move that
it simply ignores this many fold
captures like here here here here all
those captures whenever this move is
possible then it's almost always winning
until this is the win nice yeah well I
was only thinking in terms of let give
me this end game and I'm going to win
which is actually what happened I think
this end game is a win the advantages
are little bit a little bit too too
great here for black 94 was maybe a bit
more dynamic but it is saturated in the
looking a slow slowish way but yeah i
don't i'm not sure i don't think white
can't defend this in the long run well
okay well thanks for watching